Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This work is about transferring our gestures
onto a virtual human's face in a way that
is physically correct.
This means that not only the changes in the
facial geometry are transferred to a digital
character, no, no, no.
Here's how it works.
This piece of work uses a really cool digital
representation of our face that contains not
only geometry, but there is also information
about the bone and flesh and muscle structures
as well.
This means that it builds on a physically
accurate model, which synthesizes animations
where this human face is actuated by the appropriate
muscles.
We start out with a surface scan of the user,
which through a registration step, is then
converted to a set of expressions that we
wish to achieve.
The inverse physics module tries to guess
exactly which muscles are used and how they
are used to achieve these target expressions.
The animation step takes the information of
how the desired target expressions evolve
in time, and some physics information, such
as gravity or wind, and the forward physics
unit computes the final simulation of the
digital character.
So while we're talking about the effects of
gravity and wind, here you can see how this
can create more convincing outputs because
these characters really become a part of their
digital environment.
As a result, the body mass index of a character
can also be changed in both directions, slimming
or fattening the face.
Lip enhancement is also a possibility.
If we had super high resolution facial scans,
maybe a followup work could simulate the effects
of botox injections.
How cool would that be?
Also, one of my favorite features of this
technique is that it also enables artistic
editing.
By means of drawing, we can also specify a
map of stiffness and mass distributions, and
if we feel cruel enough, we can create a barely
functioning human face to model and animate
virtual zombies.
Imagine what artists could do with this, especially
in the presence of super high resolution textures
and photorealistic rendering.
Oh, my!
Another glimpse of the future of computer
graphics and animation.
Make sure to have a look at the paper for
more applications, for instance, they also
demonstrate the possibility of modifying the
chin and the jawbone.
They even have some result in simulating the
effect of Bell's palsy, which is the paralysis
of facial muscles on one side.
While we're at this high note of illnesses,
if you enjoyed this episode and would like
to support us, you can pick up really cool
perks like early access for all of these episodes
on Patreon.
The link is available in the video description.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time.